good evening ladies and gentlemen
columnist and syndicated editorial
cartoonist Ted Rahl is an award-winning
graphic novelist and the author of
nonfiction books about domestic and
international current affairs his
political cartoons appear in
approximately 100 newspapers around the
United States and from 2008 to 2009 he
was president of the Association of
American editorial cartoonists he has
won several awards for his work
including two Robert F Kennedy
Journalism Awards a Scripps Howard
national journalism award and best book
of the Year award from the American
Heart Association joining him on stage
tonight is Chris Hedges Chris has spent
nearly two decades as a foreign
correspondent in Central America the
Middle East Africa and the Balkans
he has reported for more than from more
than 50 countries and has worked for the
Christian Science Monitor National
Public Radio the Dallas Morning News and
the New York Times hedges was part of
the team of reporters at the Times
awarded a Pulitzer Prize in 2002 for the
papers coverage of global terrorism he
is also the author of several
best-selling books including war as a
force that gives us meaning and his new
book wages of rebellion the moral
imperative of revolt we're here tonight
to celebrate the release of Ted's newest
book snowden without any further ado
please welcome ted raw and chris hedges
[Applause]
hi so thanks for coming everyone
I'm Ted that's Chris I'm gonna talk a
little bit about my book and then Chris
will talk a little bit about whatever
he's going to talk about and then we'll
have a little discussion and then we'll
throw it out to the audience for Q&A so
if you have any questions comments
insults please keep them and we will
absolutely field them and like the
government we will ignore your your
insults
so can you everyone hear me OK in the
back okay so I'll talk a little bit
about the book we don't really have the
ability to do a slide show but my slide
show was just going to be pages from the
book so you could just grab a copy of
the book and look at it before you buy
numerous copies of it but I'll just go
through the thinking here with me here
Oh
closer okay okay so I will I these mics
are cleaned after every appearance right
so anyway sorry said that suggested that
I might want to do a graphic novel
biography of Edward Snowden and I was
immediately intrigued by the idea I was
really into it
but I was concerned that someone else
would do a biography in some format in
prose or otherwise and so one of the
things that one of the one of the things
I wanted to do was to make the book
discreet and and and its own thing that
would be different from say a Snowden
autobiography or a prose book but like
all books it's always the hardest thing
is format how do you get into this topic
how do you you know we know Edward
Snowden as a controversial and
fascinating figure and what he did has
evoked a lot of strong opinions on all
sides of the political spectrum
but the question is for me was how do I
get to you know what's the book what is
the book we know there's a Snowden book
but what is it so when I was asking
people about you know people were saying
well what's your next project as they
always do I said well I'm doing working
on a graphic biography of Edward Snowden
and I was shocked by how many people
told me that they didn't know who he was
including very people who are well-read
people who you know who are who are very
aware of privacy issues and I was just
amazed by that so I thought but you know
how does it that we can live in a world
where in 2013 two years ago what to me
is the most important story of my
lifetime more important than 9/11 how is
it that that story has because faded
into obscurity and then the other aspect
was that among people who knew who he
was they were very vague on the on the
particulars a lot of people said isn't
he that Russian spy or isn't he that guy
who said something I mean that's a quote
literally as I heard over and over
something about NSA or CIA I don't know
they were doing something wrong I don't
know so I realized that what he revealed
had to be stated and since laid out in
some kind of very clear concise way that
could be easily digested by just about
anybody and so I realized that part of
the book was going to have to be about
laying out these NSA programs that were
revealed in June of nineteen of 2013 to
the Guardian and the New York Times in
the Washington Post and to lay them out
and so because the only program that has
been discussed in Congress or by
President Obama in any way has been the
telephony metadata program which is the
NSA spying with the cooperation of the
telecoms like Verizon and AT&T and
Sprint on the information that's on your
phone bill that's a telephony metadata
so it's the stuff what time you made a
call where the person was how long you
talk to them what their phone number was
what your phone number was that's it
and you can get a lot of information
from that you know if you're calling an
oncologist you might have cancer or
someone close to you might have cancer
if you're calling Mother Jones magazine
to complain about your subscription not
about your magazine not arriving you're
probably not a Republican so you can
tell a lot about people from telephony
metadata and clusters of people and
subsets of clusters of people and
there's been a lot of articles about
that but there hasn't but then there's
been a lot of misdirection purposefully
by the government and by the press
that's largely controlled by or allied
with the government so for example they
keep saying well you don't have to worry
about it because that program doesn't
actually intersect the voice content of
your call and that's true they're
telling the truth about that because
they have another program that does that
and then the people who defends that
program say well you don't have to worry
about that program because it doesn't
store the calls it only intercepts the
calls and that's true totally true
because they have another program that
stores the calls for five years or
longer it's all stored on a data farm in
Utah and to make it really frightening a
lot of these documents that Snowden
stole are years old so you know the
technology has only improved since 2012
11 and 10 when those documents are dated
so probably the storage capacity is more
efficient the search abilities are
better no doubt and so the so I need I
knew that
lastly the third part of the of the of
the book beside telling his story
explaining the explaining what the
program's do the third thing had to be
about the existential dilemma faced by
this man who was literally one in a
million and by 1 in a million I mean
really 2 in 1.4 million because there
are 1.4 million Americans who had access
to some or all of the classified
documents that Edward Snowden took from
the NSA CIA and Booz Allen Hamilton
and out of those 1.4 million people who
saw brazen violations of the Fourth
Amendment here I mean let's
clear on this no one on the political
spectrum says that these programs are
legal they are not legal they say that
they're defensible that they're
necessary they're expedient but they
don't see that they're that they're
legal because they're not legal they're
not authorized under the Patriot Act
they're not authorized up there they're
violent they're massive violations of
the Fourth Amendment's protection
against unreasonable search and seizure
so they are there's no question about
that
and so the the issue really is why did
all of these for me I wondered about the
kind of society that we live in that one
over a million people could see this law
breaking on a mass scale and only
Snowden and a guy named Tom Drake who
did the similar thing but tried to work
within the system about 10 15 years ago
these two guys are the only ones who
have stepped forward in the last 15
years since not last 14 years since 9/11
at all to talk about these programs now
bear in mind also there have been
previous whistleblowers and the NSA's
effort to scoot up scoop up every bit of
information possible has been something
that has been dates back at least to the
1980s bearing in mind also that the
NSA's Charter from 1947 is only foreign
signals intelligence and what that means
is NSA is allowed legally under US law
to spy on foreigners they can spy on
foreigners on Americans when they're
talking to a foreigner but they're not
allowed to talk to an American the
intercept of American talking to an
American or emailing an American or
texting an American or whatever and so
they're doing this on a mass scale and
they started doing it on a mass scale
with a program called Escalon in the
1980s that was not widely reported upon
in the United States but was well known
in Europe and in that program
essentially made the effort to intercept
every fax transmission telex Bank wire
transfer all these communications at the
time and at the time general Hayden who
was the head of the NSA bragged that the
that that the u.s. did successfully
intercept every bit of communications in
the United States
back in the 80s so we're not talking
about anything terribly new this goes
has gone back goes back a long way
it's just much more efficient now and I
opened the book with the with the
passages from the world depicted by
George Orwell in 1984 and where people
are followed by by cameras as they move
through the streets telephone drones and
planes and helicopters track their
movements and most I think memorably is
the telescreen which is the TV that's on
the wall in Europe house and you can
never turn it off and you watch it but
it watches you whatever the government
wants to they can see what you're doing
in your room and they have it positioned
in such a way that there's almost no
privacy whatsoever in your room well the
NSA has literally this was the part that
made me open with 1984 the NSA has
literally recreated this with Smart TVs
and Snowden has revealed that the NSA
can watch you through the camera on your
phone your computer or the camera on
your Smart TV so if you have a smart TV
they can watch you and so it's it's kind
of insane they can track you through the
movement through the streets just like
they could in 1984 that's how the Boston
police and the authorities tracked that
Sarnia brothers after the Boston
Marathon bombings and they were
literally able to sit in a control room
and watched it now there's a question
about efficacy you know in the end it
was really a nicotine addiction that
caught mr. tarney off because the city
was on lockdown and a guy hankering for
a smoke
went out to his backyard and found mr.
tarney f in the back in the inn hiding
out in his boat full of bullet holes so
if we really need to encourage smoking
if we're really going to capture
terrorists and probably save trillions
of dollars on the NSA because there's
literally no evidence whatsoever that
the NSA has ever successfully in the
post 9/11 world intercepted a real
terrorist plot against the United States
of America no evidence whatsoever maybe
it's happened but nobody knows nobody on
the Senate Intelligence Committee can
say it so anyway we have this dystopian
world and we have this society that has
been somehow so
morally corrupted and I think the moral
issue is really huge here it's a matter
of right and wrong when you see law
breaking occurring at your job to say
okay well if I can't go through the
system and as Snowden said the problem
with the system and the reason the
system is broken it's because you have
to report wrongdoing to the very people
who are most responsible for it if we if
you're not willing to take that to make
that sacrifice as whistleblowers like
Daniel Ellsberg and Chelsea Manning and
several and and many others but not
nearly enough have done then there is
literally no ability whatsoever for this
system
which is so off the rails in terms of
militarism and being beholden to
corporate interests and so on and a
broken electoral system it is impossible
yeah there's no hope whatsoever it's
just like in 1984 the world that George
Orwell
portrayed when I was a kid I'm 52 years
old seemed like a possible future but
now it's our absolute present in fact
that's our past if we went to the world
of 1984 it would not be as dystopian as
what we are living in today and you know
I think I want to leave time for Chris
to talk so we can get to the discussion
so that's a little bit about Snowden
[Applause]
thanks Ted this book wait a rebellion
begins from that point from the dystopia
that Ted described what our greatest
living political philosopher Sheldon
Wolin calls inverted totalitarianism and
by that he means it's not classical
totalitarianism it doesn't find its
expression through a demagogue or a
charismatic leader but through the
anonymity of the corporate state that in
a classical totalitarian regime you have
a fascist communist revolutionary
reactionary party that overthrows a
decaying structure and replaces it in
inverted totalitarianism you have
corporate forces that purport to pay
fealty to electoral politics the
iconography and language of American
patriotism the Constitution and yet
internally have seized all of the levers
of power to render the citizen impotent
we have as the Canadian philosopher John
Ralston Saul has aptly pointed out
undergone a corporate coup d'etat in
slow-motion and his Ted explained it's
over and this book that I wrote is
really how does one resist how does one
rebel against this dystopia it
especially given the effects of climate
change we just saw through the LA Times
this massive investigative project that
came out today showing that ExxonMobil
was well aware their scientists were
well aware of climate change in global
warming decades ago and yet like the
tobacco industry denied that reality in
the name of corporate profit I mean you
know not only a criminal offense but
offense that you know may at this point
given the extent of the catastrophe may
mean the extinction of the human species
itself and so in this book I talk about
the impaired moral imperative of revolt
which of course Snowden
exemplifies and I argue that given the
incredible power of the security and
surveillance state that is arrayed
against us
coupled with militarized police forces
coupled with the evisceration of our
civil liberties finally we have to rise
up not so much for what we can achieve
but for who it allows us to become that
we can't use the word hope if we don't
resist
and that means physical resistance it
means civil disobedience sustained civil
disobedience and it means jail time this
is a passage from the book on Snowden I
thought it was kind of apt to go with
the talk tonight and Ted's book I have
been to war I have seen physical courage
but this courage is not moral courage
very few of even the bravest warriors
have moral courage for moral courage
means to defy the crowd to stand up as a
solitary individual to shun the
intoxicating embrace of comradeship to
be disobedient to Authority even at the
risk of your life for a higher principle
and with moral courage comes persecution
the American army pilot Hugh Thompson
had moral courage he landed his
helicopter between a platoon of US
soldiers and ten terrified Vietnamese
civilians during the melee massacre he
ordered his gunner to fire his m60
machine gun on the advancing US soldiers
if they began to shoot the villagers and
for this act of moral courage Thompson
like Snowden was hounded and reviled
moral courage always looks like this it
is always defined by the state as
treason the army attempted to cover up
the massacre and court martial Thompson
it is the courage to act and to speak
the truth Thompson had it Daniel
Ellsberg had it Martin Luther King had
it and what those in authority once said
about them they say today about Snowden
my country right or wrong is the moral
equivalent of my mother drunk or sober
GK Chesterton reminded us so let me
speak to you about those drunk with
power to sweep up all your email
correspondence your tweets your web
searches your phone records your file
transfers your live chats your financial
data your medical data your criminal and
civil court records and your movements
those who are washing billions upon
billions of taxpayer dollars those who
have banks of sophisticated computer
systems along with biosensors scanners
face recognition technologies and
miniature drones those who have
obliterated your anonymity your privacy
and yes your Liberty
there is no free press without the
ability of the reporters to protect the
confidentiality of those who have the
moral courage
to make public the abuse of power those
few individuals inside government who
dared to speak out about the system of
mass surveillance have been charged as
spies or hounded into exile an
omnipresent surveillance state and I
covered the East German Stasi State
creates a climate of paranoia and fear
it makes democratic descent impossible
any state that has the ability to
inflict full-spectrum dominance on its
citizens is not a free state it does not
matter if it does not use this capacity
today it will use it history has shown
should it feel threatened or seek
greater control the goal of wholesale
surveillance has had an arrant Road is
not in the end to discover crimes but to
be on hand when the government decides
to arrest a certain category of the
population the relationship between
those who are constantly watched and
tracked and those who watch and track
them is the relationship between masters
and slaves and those who wield this
unchecked power become delusional
general Keith Alexander the former
director of the National Security Agency
hired a Hollywood set designer to turn
his command center at Fort Meade into a
replica of the bridge of the Starship
Enterprise so he could sit in the
captain's chair and pretend he was
jean-luc Picard James clapper the
Director of National Intelligence had
the audacity to lie under oath
to Congress this spectacle was a rare
glimpse into the absurdist theater that
now characterizes American political
life a congressional oversight committee
holds public hearings
it is lied to it knows it is being lied
to and the person who lies knows the
committee members know he is lying and
the committee to protect their security
clearances say and do nothing
these voyeurs listen to everyone and
everything they have bugged the Conclave
that elected the new pope they bugged
the German Chancellor Angela Merkel they
bugged most of the leaders of Europe
they intercepted the talking points of
un secretary-general ban ki-moon ahead
of a meeting with President Obama
now what security threat was posed by
the Conclave of Catholic Cardinals the
German Chancellor and the UN Secretary
General they bugged businesses like the
Brazilian oil company Petrobras
and American law firms engaged in trade
deals with Indochina for shrimp and
closed cigarettes they carried out a
major eavesdropping effort focused on
the United Nations Climate Change
Conference in Bali in 2007 they bugged
their ex-lovers their wives and their
girlfriends and the NSA stores our data
in perpetuity I was a plaintiff before
the Supreme Court in a case that
challenged the warrantless wiretapping a
case dismissed because the court
believed the government's assertion that
our concern about wholesale surveillance
was in the words of the
government attorneys speculation we had
the court said no standing no right to
bring the case and we had no way to
challenge this assertion which we now
know to be a lie until Snowden in the
United States the Fourth Amendment
limits the state's ability to search and
seize to a specific place time and event
approved by a magistrate and it is
impossible to square the bluntness of
the Fourth Amendment with the arbitrary
search and seizure of all our personal
communications former Vice President Al
Gore said correctly that Snowden
disclosed evidence of crimes against the
United States Constitution we have been
fighting against mass surveillance made
no headway by appealing to the
traditional centers of power it was only
after Snowden methodically leaked
documents that disclosed crimes
committed by the state the genuine
public debate began elected officials
for the first time promised reform the
prevalent president who had previously
dismissed our questions about the extent
of state surveillance by insisting there
was strict congressional and judicial
oversight appointed a panel to review
intelligence three judges
since the Snowden revelations have ruled
on mass surveillance with two saying the
NSA spying was unconstitutional and the
third backing it none of this would have
happened
none of it without Snowden Snowden had
access to the full roster of everyone
working at the NSA he could have made
public the entire intelligence community
and undercover assets worldwide
he could have exposed the locations of
every clandestine station and their
missions he could have shut down the
intelligence system as he has said in an
afternoon but this was never his
intention he wanted only to halt the
wholesale surveillance which until he
documented it was being carried out
without our consent or our knowledge
politicians including the Democratic
candidate Hillary Clinton argue that
Snowden could have turned internal
mechanisms to have his grievances heard
but I can tell you from personal
experience that this argument is as
cogent as the offer made by the March
Hare
during the Mad Tea Party in Alice in
Wonderland have some wine the March Hare
said in an encouraging tone Alice looked
all round the table but there was
nothing on it but tea I don't see any
wine she remarked there isn't any said
the March Hare
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so how should we do this should we
jibber-jabber or should we throw it out
to the audience in typical jibber-jabber
about what they have to say I'll let you
lead it's your book okay so I think
anyone any questions come on it's gonna
be all us louder I'm sorry what
No okay your discussion of moral heroes
and the distinction between what's legal
and what's moral Kris I'm thinking about
you gave some examples Socrates the main
the main moral hero at the foundation of
the discussion well I'm a great admirer
of the philosopher Hannah Aaron who
writes quite a bit about the dilemma one
faces when they are confronted with what
Immanuel Kant calls radical evil and
when she finishes the University of
Heidelberg she writes that she had to
unlearn everything she was taught at
university in order to become a moral
being
she herself joins although she was not a
Zionist an underground scientist group
that attempts to help German Jews flee
to what was then the British Mandate of
Palestine until she's picked up by the
Gestapo almost killed expelled from the
country stripped of her German
citizenship and becomes stateless and I
think that the the this system of what
Sheldon Wolin calls inverted
totalitarianism the corporate state is
one where we as citizens have lost not
only our voice but our ability
to make you know our most basic rights
respected we have example after example
of how what it is that we as citizens
expect or desire is irrelevant to
corporate power constituent calls in
2008 across the political spectrum were
against the bailouts in Congress and yet
it passed anyway nobody wants wholesale
surveillance I sued the president in
federal court over section 1021 of the
National Defense Authorization Act which
overturns over 150 years of domestic law
and permits the US military to carry out
in essence acts of extraordinary
rendition against US citizens on the
streets of American cities we won in the
Southern District Court of New York and
then the Obama administration appealed
it and and when these people are seized
under this section they're stripped of
due process and held indefinitely and
during that two-year legal paddle after
we won in the appeal in the Second
Circuit an opinion poll went out and
that section of 10 that's section 1021
of the NDAA at a 97% disapproval rating
and what we have seen is the courts have
an essence up ended our most important
constitutional rights by judicial Fiat
that's how you get this absurd idea that
unlimited corporate cash is the right to
petition the government or a form of
free speech in you know in this case the
Second Circuit desperately did not want
to rule on as Ted pointed out the issue
of privacy in my case the use of
military as domestic police force and so
what they did is they denied my standing
and the way they did it was refer to the
case that I mentioned in my brief talk
which was the which did get to the
Supreme Court clapper
versus Amnesty International of which I
was a plaintiff challenging warrantless
wiretapping and surveillance and they
said well hedges doesn't have standing
as a plaintiff in clapper versus Amnesty
International therefore he doesn't have
a standing
in hedges versus Obama and they threw it
out we have seen it with activists Andy
fracking activists will tell you they
organized communities in Oklahoma
Pennsylvania Colorado they educate those
communities those communities passbands
and then the superstructure of the state
bans the ban
whether it's the Texas Senate whether
it's the high courts in Ohio so the the
government which is completely captive
to corporate power becomes a weapon to
criminalize and crush a legitimate
Democratic dissent and that's where we
are we have of course the wonderful
smoke and mirrors and bread and circus
and political vaudeville which is on
track to cost us seven billion dollars
and professional sports and I mean
there's all sorts of ways to distract us
but you know the the naked fist of the
state which Ted referred to is becoming
more and more apparent especially for
poor people of color where people are
just being gunned down unarmed people
are being gunned down daily in the
streets and if they're not being gunned
down and terrorized in the streets
they're being locked in cages and I will
go back to Erin she said that when you
create omnipotent policing when you
strip a segment of your population of
Rights the way we have stripped poor
people of color of their rights then
rights become privileges and once rights
become privileges they can be taken away
from everyone
you also have created as Erin points out
a legal and a physical mechanism by
which should there be unrest or should
the wider population become restive
those tools can instantly be applied to
everyone else it's almost like you know
this everything Chris said is absolutely
true and mainstream and and if you told
me even 20 years ago that if I'd heard
someone saying these things I would have
thought they were a crackpot a nun and
you know but what you're saying is
absolutely true and it's amazing to me
how
system of checks and balances turned out
to be nothing of the sort in so so
quickly I mean you know I think you know
there's there's no one thing you can
point to you but for me a great example
was the 2000 the disputed Florida
election you know it's like well the US
Supreme Court was never supposed to hear
that case because in the United States
elections are decided by the states so
when the Florida State Supreme Court
ruled for a recount ordered a recount in
certain counties that was supposed to be
the last word and the US Supreme Court
even took pains in Bush v Gore to point
out that this was not a precedent
shouldn't be relied upon in the future
and yet nevertheless they stepped in
they ruled they installed Bush who
didn't win the state of Florida right
that's the part that's would not have
won if a full recount had occurred and
one can obviously criticize Al Gore's
strategy of not asking for a statewide
recount which was foolish for
statistical reasons as well as for
because you would imagine there'd be a
more a bigger democratic undercount
in Republican counties than there would
be in democratic counties so I wonder
how Gore's math skills are but I but I
still the thing that's still amazing to
me is he was installed and I remember
when that decision came through I lived
on Morningside Drive overlooking Harlem
and I expected to hear glass start
breaking I expected to hear people
screaming in the streets I expected what
would have happened in any number of
other countries around the world in
terms of unrest protests and so on and
nothing happened and I just wonder is
there something about the American
character or is there something about
the place we are in as a society and
within in stuck in this political
structure or have we all been
propagandized as as through our schools
and our and through advertising and our
popular culture to not resist not react
to act like we're all just just take it
and keep going on
the problem is that when they carry out
you know an egregious violation of norms
it's not immediately apparent what they
have done there's a great book called
define Hitler by Sebastian Hoffner he
was a lawyer in the law courts in the
early 30s when 1933 when the Nazis take
power and he he sees how all of the
effort the party makes to subvert the
law and so that on the surface things
appear as if there's a continuity from
what went before when in fact there was
a kind of radical legal change that
becomes the structure by which you
impose a totalitarian system that was
true even in Stalinist Russia if you go
back and look you know at the early
years up to the 20s there was opposition
there was a dissident press yes the
anarchists and others were brutally
repressed but it takes time and there's
a moment in Hoffner x' book where he
describes the fire in the Reichstag
which becomes the excuse by the Nazis to
impose martial law and the next morning
everyone gets up and goes to work and
takes the kids to school and he said
actually people there were people who
congregated I think he was in Leipzig
but he said the Social Democrats were so
frightened they all fled to Switzerland
in their cars and he said people's kind
of said well kind of what people say
about Trump well at least you know they
have the courage of their convictions
however repugnant those convictions are
so so what we have seen is a very
similar kind of process and corporate
totalitarianism is a different species
from other forms of totalitarianism but
no less permission and in fact in terms
of the technological capacity to monitor
and control the government far more
frightening than past systems and I
covered the Stasi state in East Germany
so what's your
scene and what you allude to is that
you're right that it was an incredibly
radical moment and let us take a moment
to defend Ralph Nader he did not elect
George Bush this became the way the
Democratic Party sought to demonize
Nader who terrified them and who they
had to destroy because he actually
represented the interests of working men
and women and defied corporate power no
one's been fighting corporate power
longer and harder and better than Ralph
but you're right that this this I mean
you're right to point that out as a kind
of seismic moment but I think it's I
mean we are certainly you know utterly
illusions we're probably the most
illusion Society on the planet and
entranced by all of these kind of
electronic hallucinations that are now
in our handheld devices but I think that
the the the crux of this issue is that
when this transformation takes place in
any totalitarian system it's largely
imperceptible and then when it is
perceptible it's too late yes
- and I wanted to kind of just touch on
what Chris um said the last time he
spoke about you know his father and
staying at the New York Times or putting
your career would have been betraying
your father and I mean I've always
studied the family system like all my
life because to me that's kind of the
root of so many of our problems is that
we just don't have really good leaders
people to give the young coming into
this world that leverage and to stand up
for what's right and I I mean I tried to
bring this out all my life and it was I
was not popular because I could see the
lack of fitness the lack of health a
lack of just like high standards and
standing up for what was right I mean
that's such a young age and I was always
trying to get people to reach form or to
stand up for more to try to be more than
just having a job and you know paying
your mortgage and having kids and you
know and I would always be pointing out
just the low standard that was set that
people just I mean like you had to dig a
hole in the floor they set the standards
so low and they would they would make
excuses for if you pointed out something
they would make excuses you know going
down rather than up you know just kind
of let me let me just toggle I mean
what's your what happened and we can go
back and I spent a book death of liberal
class talking about this process you
created a system of mass propaganda
through the creole Commission or the
committee for public information in
World War one that destroyed our radical
and progressive movements and then
morphed into you know moved to Madison
Avenue began working on behalf of
corporations which through propaganda up
up ended or overturned traditional
American values of thrift
self-effacement hard work
communitarianism and replaced it with
hedonism and the cult of the self
profligate consumption and so what we
often times today refer to as and i
think this gets to your point where it
refers to as American values are in fact
corporate
posed values I mean the anxiety we feel
over brands and how to identify this is
all instilled and what's fascinating is
that you read Bernays or lastwell or you
know walter Lippmann and others that are
quite open about it and that sense of
individual preoccupation even to the
extent that it's infected spirituality
so the question is not in the
traditional religious sense how is it
with a strange or how is it with the
outcasts how is it with a demonized how
is it with the other its how is it with
me which is just a reflection of the
narcissism of the culture and that has I
think been a very disempowering and
pernicious force I think this kind of
brings us to like one of the questions
in in my book about Snowden I was
wondering why was stowed indifferent why
was he willing to upend and maybe
possibly even sacrifice his life what
was it about his upbringing that that or
his background that brought him to that
point and the bottom line is there's
nothing he has you know his parents are
divorced so what half of Americans his
age have divorced parents he was in the
Boy Scouts
so was i I mean he learned basic
American traditional American values of
trustworthiness and an honesty and
obviously what he witnessed at NSA and
at Booz Allen Hamilton was dishonest and
with the American people there's what to
me was intriguing was that if there's
any one incident that really turned him
against the NSA and the security state
it was a very Picayune kind of moment he
was at he was stationed at in Geneva at
the u.s. at the US Embassy as a CIA guy
undercover IT and he heard fellow CIA
agents he was at the CIA at the time
talking about how they'd flipped a Swiss
bank or whose records they wanted access
to and the way they compromised him is
they they took him out got him drunk
then called up the local police and had
him a
did for drunk driving and then showed up
and miraculously rescued him
and they were laughing about it because
that compromised him to the point where
he was he had to turn over the documents
that he was he had the secret banking
documents that he was had kept from the
heretofore from the CIA and and Snowden
thought it was absolutely disgusting he
thought it was unamerican he thought it
was cheating he thought it was
underhanded and gross and not the
country that he wanted to be from but
it's really a very basic example of it's
a very standard bit of spy craft not at
all sophisticated I mean if you read Len
Deighton or Frederick Forsyth you've
you've seen this and more you know this
is no big deal
so what is it about Snowden I mean you
know I interviewed Thomas Drake the
other NSA whistleblower who I talked to
talked about in Washington and whose
career was completely destroyed he was
an upper-level executive at NSA and when
he tried to attempted to go through the
system reported his his concerns about
not only privacy violations but also
wasting of billions of dollars of
taxpayer money on inefficient programs
really it was corruption people were
benefit of private contractors that were
connected to these to the officials that
were approving these programs were
benefiting these he went to the
Inspector General he did everything that
you're supposed to do as a whistleblower
never they lost they raided his house
they set out to destroy his career they
blackballed him they destroyed his
marriage he ended up and now he's
working in a at the Genius Bar at an
Apple Store now it's in in in Maryland
that's where he works and I talked to
him about this like well what is it
about you
you know why you there like what about
all year he said kept saying well it was
wrong what I saw was wrong and I'm and I
kept insisting
yes but what about your colleagues they
all saw the same stuff they didn't say
anything they didn't think it was wrong
or if they did think it was wrong they
didn't think it rose to the level of
something
worth sacrificing or taking it a risk
over and he kept and he's just he
couldn't I realized that after a while
that he was just hardwired this way it
was just something about him he couldn't
put his finger on it the closest he
could get to was that he came from he
had been raised in Vermont which has a
spirit which has local governance and
town meetings and true you know local
democracy and feels like you know very
intimate and you feel like you're
participating in your government much
more so than perhaps in other places but
there was nothing you know I mean these
there's something about to me Snowden as
a role model he's what I would aspire my
I want my son to be you know as someone
who does the right thing even when it
hurts that's the definition of integrity
it is and like when so you know I mean
where did we go wrong I mean Chris's
work talks a lot about morality and in
this country morality is the Providence
of the right in the political debate
it's always and what we're really
talking about is moralism not moral
morality more moralism is you know where
are you sticking your genitalia but the
morals are about what's right and what's
wrong
truly what is the bigger issue versus
the smaller issue like for example
Edward Snowden had to decide which of
his ODEs he was going to violate his
oath to protect the Constitution or to
protect classified data from being
revealed out to outside sources he
couldn't do both he had to choose one
and it was the jean-paul Sartre wrote in
a notebook for an ethics but something I
have like bookmarked I always referred
to it what he defined as the
quintessential existential dilemma which
is I am handed a gun there is a gun to
my head and I and I am told shoot that
other guy or I will shoot you what is
the right choice Sartre says of course
the right choose choice is to say [ __ ]
you and get shot and die point being the
right choice isn't always any fun but
it's still the right choice
well that's Socrates
you know it's better to suffer wrong
than to do wrong errant when she writes
about those who stand up to defy radical
evil said it's not those who say you
know we shouldn't do this or this Auden
to be done it's those who say I can't
there's just something deep down as a
theologian Reinhold Niebuhr calls a
sublime madness
and in this book I spent a lot of time
interviewing those who I believe are
endowed with sublime madness
Mumia abu-jamal jeremy hammond who
hacked into Stratford and released 5
million emails including emails that
showed that the government and private
security firms were attempting to link
nonviolent occupy movements with
al-qaeda we used it in our trial Julian
Assange and others and and you know one
of the problems is that we look back in
history at these figures these great
resistance figures Malcolm X Fannie Lou
Hamer Sitting Bull and you know we kind
of hold them up but we're unable to see
those figures within our own midst
because the state so and Snowden would
certainly be one of them because the
state so effectively demonizes them and
makes us afraid to identify with them
and stand up for them and that was that
was true for all of our great resistance
figures and prophets and and martyrs
people forget you know how hated a
figure even Martin Luther King was while
he was alive these are and and and if
you know history is important but
oftentimes I think we we don't learn the
lessons of history we don't understand
what it means to make moral choice to
take more risk and
and the cost that always come with
taking moral risks because if there
aren't any costs it's probably not much
of a moral stance it's you know I mean
it's interesting to me about Snowden you
know this is in the this isn't history
it's right now and he's such a typical
American guy you know I mean he's you
know he looks ordinary he's he's you
know he's white he's a technic rat he
started out as a right winger he was a
right-wing libertarian voted for Ron
Paul in 2008 donated money to Ron Paul
he's an American kid from South Carolina
raised in Crofton Maryland it's you know
I mean really it's he's probably more
relatable to the average American and
also the fact that he's so young 29
years old when he did this I think
somehow you know it somehow is different
from you know a Rosa Parks or someone
like that who is just you're sort of
like how could I be Rosa Parks I don't
think I can be Rosa Parks but I think I
could be Edward Snowden except I would
have never been hired by the NSA to do
something like that
in fact when I went to Columbia and when
they had a jobs fair when I was 19 I
went they had a CIA recruiting booth and
I went and talked to them because I had
silly fantasies about carrying
microfiche and the sole of my shoe and
and having dead drops in Red Square
and I went to talk to them and they said
they said yeah we're never gonna we're
never gonna hire you and I said why not
and they said well you you you attended
socialist meetings on campus and I said
communists also and he and the inside
say well we only hire Mormons from Utah
which is why we do so well in the
intelligence community
any other questions yes let me let me
let me get someone who hasn't sorry it's
got several questions one is that is
unauthorized illegal government
surveillance little louder the content
of the phone conversations that they did
you they do decode and they're the phone
calls they get stored in some kind of a
data form someplace
yes it's stored in a data farm in
Bluffdale Utah which has been its
massive and it's being expanded all the
time and it's been built with hundreds
of billions of dollars of your tax
dollars now could government use this
data to against individuals in a court
of law well I mean Chris alluded to this
earlier I mean the thing is the vast
majority of this data as things stand
will never be looked at
it's 99.9999% of it's it's on those
servers and what's happened is that as
chris alert looted to earlier in the
past you need it in his reading he said
you know you need whenever someone fell
under suspicion of wrongdoing they could
be searched or tracked or followed but
that you needed a warrant from a judge
from a magistrate and that no law and
since nuts in recent i would say since
9/11 in particular but before that too
but certainly after 9/11 the new
paradigm has been as the NSA says they
want to collect everything so what they
do is they collect every bit every
communication they store them and then
they search at their leisure for
clusters for patterns and yes for
individuals so the question is you know
even if you believe right now that
President Obama is the bestest president
we will ever have and that our
government is the bestest government we
will ever have
just like Candide and you believe in it
this the fact is presidents change
regimes change do you want to will
president Donald Trump or president Ted
Cruz behave
differently and use that information
differently possibly and you know I like
to tell the story about when I became a
French citizen I'm born in the United
States but my mother's French and when I
was 18 it was it was 1981 and Reagan had
just become president so and there was a
lot of talk that there might be a war
and a draft so I did the patriotic thing
and I ran up to 5th Avenue in 74th
Street and got in line and declared my
French citizenship and there was a line
around the block of guys about 18 19
years old singing the Marseillaise
waiting to get in and the and so when I
finally got my citizenship papers I got
an ID card a passport and and then they
handed me a birth certificate and on the
birth certificate it said birthplace
Pal Pina and I was like helping young
I'm born in Cambridge Massachusetts and
he's like there's a mistake no no no no
you're born in PAL Pina and they
explained to me that during world at the
beginning of World War two when the
Vichy authorities and then the Nazi
authorities the Gestapo and so on when
they invaded France they captured all
the census and police data records all
the post mostly kept on postcards and
filing cards that showed religious
identification and whether someone was
born overseas or not and when they came
time to deport they deported Jews first
and state and people who were born
overseas first to the camps so at the
end of the war the French government
passed a new law that stated that they
would no longer maintain those records
so the French government does not know
exactly how many say Arabs there are in
France they haven't they have a
guesstimate but they don't have they
don't have a list of them there's no way
to get it and for example they don't
know how many people were born outside
of France because they destroy those
records so in in every file supposedly I
don't know if this is really true but
supposedly in in French archives I'm
listed as being from pepino so a few
years ago I was in Paris driving the
wrong way against six lanes of traffic
on the sean's alizée
when a cop pulled me over with his cute
little KP and and he's like you know
what the [ __ ] are you doing and I said
and I saw my hat and I showed him my
passport and and he went he ran my
information and he's like Pio Pio and I
he's like very mo and I'm like whee
he's like I mean Pepe neon is like the
Mississippi of France okay I mean it's
like this on the Spanish border it has a
really strange accent there's like no
way could anyone who learned English in
the United States have a pale pinyon
accent it's impossible but he just kept
insisting and I was like whee and
there's nothing he could do about it and
I was like bye and he was just like
Vuitton so so the point is that that in
that there's some information that
shouldn't be in anyone's hands I
personally have an awesome moral person
but if I had this information there's a
bunch of people who I'd really screw
over if I could get into those files
it's more that when a society breaks
down the reason all totalitarian systems
keep files on all of their citizens is
that the moment the power structure the
power elite feels threatened they have
the capacity to pull up those files and
criminalize entire groups of people it
based on utterly innocuous data but data
that they interpret in such a way as to
tar that individual with criminal or
terroristic activity that's why
totalitarian states collect data on
everyone that's why the Stasi state did
it that's why Stalin did it that's why
the fascists did it and we have now
handed that tool it's not really a
matter I think necessarily of
individuals it is about this corporate
cabal that has seized power and that
growing awareness on the part of the
wider public that everything they've
been told about globalization and
neoliberalism is a lie it is seen well
sucked upwards into the hands of a
rapacious predatory ally it has not
further democracy it is in fact
obliterated
democracy it has savaged the environment
it is and so as that reality is
understood and I think we're seeing in
this election manifested in this
election as the state you know loses its
credibility then it will increasingly as
it is resort to harsher more naked forms
of oppression that Orwell outlined in
1984 and remember we got two great
dystopian thinkers Huxley and Orwell but
we got Huxley first we got you know
access to cheap mass-produced goods and
spectacle and entertainment and easy
credit and pharmaceuticals and now it's
gone and the pharmaceuticals are still
there but but everything else is and and
and as you know those forms of control
are less officious then we get the more
naked forms and and more brutal and
violent forms of control of which the
security and surveillance state is you
know kind of first and foremost among
that system they're asked whether I have
a website I do not have a website I do
not tweet I don't have a Facebook page
and I don't own a television Instagram I
don't have anything I have a phone and I
have 5,000 books my house anyone else
okay yes that'll be the last one
well you can ask Secretary of State
Clinton she's asking just to repeat the
question why Snowden is still living in
Russia because they revoked his US
passport and he couldn't get to Ecuador
well here's the here's the situation if
there's another place it's actually one
of the things that's in the book that
that corrects some of the MIS reporting
that that has occurred about this issue
so the US government asserted falsely
that the Chinese allowed Snowden to
leave on an invalid passport in order to
poke poker the eye of the US government
but that's false that didn't happen when
he boarded his plane in Hong Kong he had
a valid passport but if you have a
passport you ever noticed there's the
new ones have a little chip logo on the
front because there's a microchip inside
and you might foolishly think that
that's for your convenience to allow you
to zip through JFK and in a jiffy but
really this is a tool of state control
to do exactly what then Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton did who in my view
this disqualified this action
disqualifies her from the presidency as
much as her vote to invade Iraq she she
said I mean she turned off his passport
while he was in the air to to Moscow he
was only supposed to change planes in
Moscow and when he appeared at Share
motivo - he went to the transit dusk he
was supposed to continue onward to
Havana Cuba but they told him there was
that he think he couldn't board because
he didn't have a passport valid passport
anymore which is kind of if you think
about it kind of insane that the u.s.
gave the State Department can just flip
a switch and turn you off like that and
by the way it's just parenthetically
from a national security point of view
let's just assume that they didn't know
whether Snowden still had those
documents with him so you're gonna
strand him in Russia of all places
pretty stupid
so I mean you know he fess B could have
just like taken that stuff off him
there's nothing that anyone could have
done about it so is a really boneheaded
move
and completely immoral in so many ways
but he was supposed to he had been
invited to go to Ecuador and he would
have been able to I think that that
options no longer on the table the
problem is that you know it's just
geography he's in Russia right so how
does he get to another country that
would host him without passing over
airspace that's either controlled
directly or indirectly by the United
States you know just I don't know if you
recall this episode but the president of
Ecuador was visiting Moscow on a trade
function a trade meeting and and then
there was a rumor that the u.s. got that
Snowden was aboard his plane and the
Austrians forced him to the Bolivian
President the Bolivian president sorry
the Bolivian President and then the
Austrians forced the Bolivian President
to land and you know he was really angry
and there was some apparently some risk
to his life in this in this in this
action so risking the life of a head of
a foreign head of state to try to
capture what a guy who Obama
characterized as a 29 year old hacker is
it's kind of really over the top but
that's what would happen to Snowden if
he got on a plane he can't get anywhere
he can only go to countries that border
Russia and hope for the best so I mean
you know you know he could go to
Kazakhstan I guess
could you talk a little bit about what
you think are the weak points or weak
points in the culture of acquiescence
that we're living in of American culture
sure
well that's another program
what's happening in the United States
reminds me of what happened in
Yugoslavia which I covered as a foreign
correspondent where in essence you have
political paralysis the inability on the
part of the state to respond and that
political paralysis is carried out by a
self-identified liberal elite it's not
really a liberal elite figures like
Clinton you noted as much damage to
working men and women in this country as
Ronald Reagan Obama has only carried on
that trajectory but what happens and I
think we're seeing it within these
elections is that when people rise up
with a legitimate frustration and anger
and despair and hopelessness is that
they turn not only on the
self-identified liberal elite which has
been ineffectual which has served this
cabal in this case of corporate
oligarchs but they turn on liberal
values themselves and that's why we have
such powerful proto-fascist movements in
the United States whether they're
Christo fascists whether they're
nativists whether they're Tea Party you
know militias and they've always been
part of the virus of American society
going all the way back to the slave
patrols the Pinkertons the baldwin-felts
a clan but what happens is that you
direct that rage towards the vulnerable
towards Muslims undocumented workers
African Americans liberals feminists
intellectuals and that we are watching
you see it in Trump rallies and what
we're that is just part of the physical
and moral disintegration of the society
the use of wholesale violence I mean we
live in a city where one of our fellow
citizens was choked to death unarmed
never committed a crime choked to death
and killed on a city sidewalk and none
of the police went to jail the the
danger of that is that the you know the
very kind of neo listing violence that
we're seeing
right now between Palestine and Israel
where the Palestinians have been so
crushed that they're kind of lashing out
with this in Ko hate but understandable
fury and to understand is not to condone
but understandable is is is also
happening in the United States we've had
26 or 27 assassinations of
law-enforcement officials including two
in New York City this year now these are
not confrontations
these are assassinations I hope this is
not a pattern
but I think that there's so much
evidence now that the society has seized
up that the society really isn't
functioning at all I mean we watch the
arms industry hollow the nation out from
the inside officially 54% of
discretionary spending in fact that
doesn't count Veterans Affairs it
doesn't account for the nuclear weapons
program it doesn't account for all the
black budgets like these intelligence
streams that were not allowed to see my
best estimates were spending 1.6 1.7
trillion dollars a year on endless
futile Wars which we've lost in
countries like Iraq and Afghanistan the
Taliban controls more of Afghanistan
than they did when we invaded 14 years
ago but of course for a you know a small
corporate cabal Northrop Grumman and
General Dynamics it's great its money
its profit more as a business and and
and and so you know we are as American
citizens being tasked or forced through
austerity the collapse of our
infrastructure repressive measures I
mean you drive through one American
former industrial city after another
it's a wasteland it's being taken out on
us and that's how empires you know all
go down we're no exception Joseph
Tainter in the collapse of complex
societies chronicled how you know all of
the characteristics that empires die and
and and unfortunately you know that
pathology of death
is one that you know unleashes some very
dark spectral forces America is a very
violent society unlike Canada for
instance we're a very very violent
culture so I mean you know the end of
literacy the rise of spectacle the you
know the way verifiable fact now long
especially on the airwaves
it no longer matters it's all you know
it's it you know whatever however you're
made to feel that's kind of what Fox
News is about you know they're just so
many signs of the final sign being that
the harsh forms of control that Empire
uses on the outer reaches of empire
drones militarized police wholesale
surveillance have now migrated back to
the heart of empire so a night raid in
East New York
looks no different from a night raid in
Fallujah long barreled weapons Kevlar
vests and and that's not accidental
facilities got it he said what destroyed
Athenian democracy is that the tyranny
Athens imposed on others that finally
imposed on itself thank you very much
and just thank you everyone for coming
tonight the only thing I'd like to add
to that is that no I'd like to answer
that question nothing's really settled
in American politics and I feel like
that's a uniquely American thing you
know it's in in other countries if
there's a dispute over an issue there's
a battle and then eventually one side
prevails and then it's over and mostly
yes the losing side goes home licks its
wounds and is sad but it's over but the
United States I mean the South doesn't
admit that they were wrong during the
Civil War
we never despite Sherman's march they
were not crushed there that this
resistance is not gone the Confederate
battle battle flag still flies above
state capitols they never got over it
and if you just look at all these like
battles it's so hard for liberalism or
progressivism to triumph even when it
does triumph even when
has the support of an overwhelming
majority of Americans there's still that
the losers don't admit they've lost and
the winners don't make them admit that
they've lost so nothing ever gets
settled it's like we never move forward
I find it just I mean as a political
commentator I find it just baffling
we're always I mean if I could we could
live a thousand years and assume this
society would last that long which it
won't
it's like there's you know we could be
having the same stupid arguments over
the same [ __ ] forever and ever but
anyway thanks everyone for coming of
course Chris and I will be happy to sign
your numerous copies of your of your
book our books that you're buying and if
you don't buy our books in which in
which case you're foolish at least buy a
book thanks for coming thank you ladies
and gentlemen for coming we ask that you
please remain seated for just one moment
while we make the stage ready for you if
you have a book to get signed if you
haven't purchased a book yet we do still
have them both available back at the
registers towards the back of the store
thank you